Algunos pares ordenados para la función lineal "x"
se dan en la tabla de a continuación.
¿Que ecuación se utilizó para generar esta tabla?
y bueno, si te das cuenta aquí tenemos
un montón de puntos,
los cuales son puntos de esta función lineal,
es decir, cuando "x" vale 1
entonces "y" vale 11,
cuando "x" vale 2 "y" vale 16
y así todos los demás.
Y bueno, de todas estas rectas que tengo aquí,
una de ellas va a ser la recta que me va a generar,
todos los puntos que tengo aquí en esta tabla
así que intentemos probar con el primer punto,
cuando "x" vale 1, "y" vale 11,
y bueno, vámonos ecuación por ecuación para ver
cuál de éstas es la que representa estos puntos.
A ver, si "x" vale 1 entonces "y" vale 11
¿qué pasa si aquí sustituyó a "x" por 1?
me quedaría 4, que multiplica a 1,
esto más 1
y bueno 4 por 1 más 1,
esto es lo mismo que 5,
eso quiere decir que en esta recta,
cuando "x" vale 1
"y" vale 5, no 11,
por lo tanto
podemos cancelar esta opción
porque date cuenta que no llegamos al valor
de 11 que nos dice la tabla.
Para la ecuación que sea la respuesta
de esta función lineal,
tiene que generar todos estos valores de la tabla
es decir, que dado cualquier valor que le
meta de "x" de esta tabla
me debe de generar su correspondiente
"y" que está también aquí.
Bien, ahora intentemos para la segunda ecuación,
"y" es igual a 3"x" más 8
cuando "x" vale 1
entonces me quedaría 3 por 1,
lo cual es 3 más 8, lo cual es 11,
parece ser que si funciona,
ahora vamos a intentar con el segundo punto
para ver si también funciona.
Cuando "x" vale 2,
"y" debe de valer 16
y aquí, ¿que me quedaría?
me quedaría 3 por 2,
ok, más 8,
y bueno 3 por 2 es 6,
6 más 8 es 14
y no me da 16,
por lo tanto aquí,
cuando "x" vale 2
"y" vale 14, lo cual no es 16,
y por lo tanto,
está parecía ser una buena candidata para hacer nuestra respuesta...
sin embargo date cuenta que
cuando "x" vale 2, "y" no vale 16,
por lo tanto, no es nuestra respuesta.
Ok, pues es hora de intentar con la tercera
"y" es igual a "5x" más 6
y bueno ¿qué pasa si sustituimos el valor de "x" por 1?
me quedaría 5 por 1,
lo cual es 5 más 6 es 11.
¡De lujo! hasta aquí vamos bien,
ahora, vamos a probar con el valor de 2,
si "x" vale 2, entonces me va a quedar 5 por 2,
lo cual es 10,
10 más 6 ¡perfecto! es 16
y en este momento, creo que está me parece una candidata que suena bastante bien,
esta ecuación es una candidata que me
está sonando a que es la respuesta,
y es que ¡es más!
ya podríamos concluir que todos los demás puntos,
sí están generados por esta recta
porque si nosotros decimos que dos de estos puntos, los genera esta ecuación...
entonces los otros dos también van a
ser generados por esta ecuación
¿y cómo puedo saber eso?
bueno, porque recuerda que
dos puntos definen una recta
pero de todas maneras vamos a corroborar
con estos otros dos puntos
para ver si llegamos a que esta,
en efecto, es mi solución.
¿Que pasa cuando "x" vale 7?
Bueno, cuando "x" vale 7
me queda 5 por 7
5 por 7 = 35,
35 más 6,
de lujo, es 41
¿y qué pasa cuando "x" vale 9?
cuando "x" vale 9,
bueno, pues me quedaría,
5 por 9 lo cual es 45
45 más 6, lo cual es 51,
y ¡de lujo!
es justo lo que tenemos aquí
por lo tanto, esta es la respuesta
correcta de este ejercicio
ya no es necesario fijarnos en las demás,
porque ésta es
la que cumple todos estos puntos
y por lo tanto,
es la respuesta de este problema,
es decir que esta ecuación
"y" es igual a 5"x" más 6
me da los valores de esta tabla.
me genera esta tabla, es decir...
cuando "x" vale 1,
"y" vale 11
cuando "x" vale 2,
"y" vale 16
cuando "x" vale 7,
"y" vale 41
y cuando "x" vale 9,
"y" vale 51.